the more you give it a a context the
more
the cathartic escapist feeling you feel
when
the guy does win and the guy does fight
his way through it just shoot it in a
way that
you don't normally shoot a film shoot it
like a student film use a small camera
don't use a big crew don't use a lot of
lights
yeah the image of the hero is always a
metaphor for something going on within
the character
especially in a movie like this where he
doesn't have superpowers he actually
builds the suit with his own two hands
and
invents himself and i just sat down at
my computer not thinking anybody would
read it
and certainly i didn't think anybody
would make it and i wrote the script
swingers in about two weeks
i showed it to my friends i based the
characters sort of on my friends to give
them a laugh because i know they would
read it i showed it to my agent
really the first draft you just hate it
you hate yourself you hate
you're tired you hit your computer and
nothing that you're doing is of any
value and
you just have to push through it it's
not a it's not a
frontal lobe process you just get in
touch with your
you just let your the part of your brain
right that you don't have any control
over
you push through you get that draft and
then you read it
and then you then you have then you have
close friends read it and then you
figure out if it's any good
[Music]
among all the heroes in the marvel
universe why iron man
that was that for me iron man was um
well it was something it was one of the
titles that marvel
the studio had the rights to was the
biggest hero all their big boys had been
already uh sold off to other studios
like spider-man
and x-men and daredevil
so iron man was a second-tier hero
but part of the original pantheon you
know the old he's been around for 40
years
i liked him because he was a hero that
was a peer to me so i could tell a story
that i could relate to it wasn't about a
kid in high school
i also like that he was a normal person
that built the
suit as opposed to somebody who was had
some magical
thing happen to him that created his
heroic powers
so you could set it in a very real world
that i think played into my strengths
and sensibility
and then also i felt that cgi could
handle
an iron suit more than an organic figure
and it was a story that you couldn't
tell before cg because of all the things
he does with the flying and the weapons
and all those things
so it seemed like a fresh story that was
well suited for our mo for this moment
in time well you gotta do the origin
right you gotta do the origin story uh i
guess you could gloss over the origin
story
um but in the case of iron man i felt
that the the building of the suit for
the first time and
the the development of the hero was an
important step
especially since tony stark starts off
as a guy that many people might
find distasteful and unlikable and
you know the the image of the hero is
always a metaphor for something going on
within the character
especially in a movie like this where he
doesn't have superpowers he actually
builds the suit with his own two hands
and invents himself so the idea of a man
reinventing himself
is really compelling as a filmmaker and
so
i was drawn to the origin story of him
starting off as tony stark the famous
billionaire bachelor
weapons manufacturer and futurist and
and then being captured forced to build
a weapon and instead
coming to a certain epiphany about the
way he's been living his life and
and and then building this first version
of the iron man suit what we call the
mark one
and breaking out of captivity using it
and then what happens when he returns
home
so that was the chunk of the history of
the comic books that i felt was most
appropriate for introducing the world
to iron man and so we just kicked around
town and
i decided to try my hand at writing and
i just sat down at my computer not
thinking anybody would read it
and certainly i didn't think anybody
would make it and i wrote the script
swingers in about two weeks
you wrote the script in two weeks yeah
what happened then
i showed it to my friends i based the
characters sort of on my friends to give
them a laugh because i know they would
read it i showed it to my agent
and she liked the script so much that
she went out with it and people wanted
to buy it and develop it and
develop it with you starring no no no
with me i with me like in a supporting
role and as a producer
but basically it would have been taken
away from me and i sat in my first story
meeting
i don't know if you ever saw the film
the big picture with kevin bacon but
there's a there's a wonderful
there's a great scene in there where
he's sitting down and he's about to make
his first movie
and the suggestions that pour his way
from these
executives are like this is great but
how about making it in the summertime
instead of the winter time and what this
is how about putting the whole thing in
vegas and how about
switching this character to a woman and
by the time i finished my head was
spinning
and i i decided to set up a reading to
show them what the script could sound
like with the right people before they
wanted me to make the changes and i used
the cast that you saw in the film
we did a reading and the reading went so
well that my agent said let's
try to make this movie this way instead
of trying to change it
to fit somebody else's yeah and we did
readings for like two years after that
to try to raise money
to raise 250 000 well we thought we
needed closer to you know 10 times that
to make it as written
it wasn't until doug lyman the director
came with uh he had an investor he had
worked with this is arthur lyman's son
and northland is a very famous attorney
yeah and and now doug is a very famous
director you know what i mean
which is what did he bring to it he
decided to just shoot it in a way that
you don't normally shoot a film shoot
like a student film use a small camera
don't use a big crew don't use a lot of
lights
yeah don't do it in the way that you're
you know almost like hollywood shuffle
where they just did it they did what
they had to do to get the film in the
can
and 250 000 was enough to get it in the
can when you're directing as a
supporting role like happy hogan it was
really tough because i really had to be
there for
for robert and for gwyneth and i had to
help them with
their scene and i was just a supporting
player so it was actually very
distracting
and if you look at iron man 1 and 2
where i'm worrying about all that you
can see my performance is kind of
you know uh not that not that exciting
but in iron man 3 when i have to worry
about any of that i had a lot of fun
messing around on a movie like chef
where i'm the lead
you actually use your acting to help
direct especially when you're working
like with mj anthony who plays my 10
year old son
because you're right there in the scene
with him and you could really help pull
a performance out
and i leave a lot of room for improv and
and being the writer i could really
guide the scene if i want to change some
things or try things
i use multiple cameras so on a small
movie like this it's a very helpful tool
on the big ones it's kind of distracting
to be honest with you
i learned that i learned well from
talking to george lucas actually because
i'm working on star wars for the
mandalorian
i we had a long talk with each other and
and the one thing he said to me is
remember john we the real audience for
all stories and and all myths because he
really is a
joseph campbell inherent he said the
story the
the myth is designed for the kids that
are coming of age
we enjoy the stories as adults but
really storytelling
is about imparting the wisdom of the
previous generations onto
the children who are becoming adults and
and giving them a context for how to
behave
and and how to learn the lessons of the
past without without making mistakes on
their own i mean that's the hope is that
you could teach them
how to avoid all the hardship but yet
garner all the wisdom
and so i think a film like lion king is
really the purest form of storytelling
in that you are
dealing with the biggest themes that we
deal with as humans about loss about
about each generation replacing the
previous one about
living a life of responsibility and
stepping up
when it when you are called upon in the
face of tremendous suffering that life
presents to you especially in a world
like
the animal kingdom but that is a
glorious story and even though there's
tremendous suffering
uh it is a net gain and if you live your
life
in in harmony with the world around you
and you go on the spiritual journey that
all these great myths
um uh discuss that there is something
transformative and uplifting about it
and that's the mono myth it's the hero's
journey
and ultimately the reward for a life
well lived
and and that's something that as you get
older you start to appreciate more
because life feels very finite and you
see
the next generation coming up and you
relate more to mufasa than you do to
simba
and i take comfort in those themes and i
like it i love sharing that with the
next generation and knowing that this
will be
left behind even as our generation
passes you wrote swingers
and chef in like under 30 days like in a
month or so
and as a screenwriter i was just
wondering what's that moment you know
that you're writing a really good script
in such a short amount of time you
honestly don't know if it's good
um i mean that as a joke i mean what uh
stephen king described the first draft
as uh as
rowing across the ocean in the bathtub
and
really the first draft you just hate it
you hate yourself you hate
you're tired you hit your computer
everything on the internet is awesome
and nothing that you're doing is of any
value and you just have to push through
it it's not a
it's not a frontal lobe process you just
get in touch with your you just let your
the part of your brain right that you
don't have any control over
you push through you get that draft and
then you read it
and then you then you have then you have
close friends read it and then you
figure out if it's any good
but for me the fact that both of these
came out in a matter of weeks
is a good indication that there was
something building up subconsciously
that i
had to do and and years build up to it i
wish i could do it if i could do this
every year i would love to
but i just you know it's almost 20 years
between it hitting me
and i think it's because you you build
up this uh
it's like sap in a tree like a maple
tree it slowly sort of drips out and
then you have like it's all there
uh and it's a great feeling but writing
honestly i do all those different things
writing is by far
the most challenging the hardest the
scariest one
and then most rewarding when this
happens because this is i mean i can't
tell you
it really honestly does feel like i'm a
chef and this is a meal and i serve
food it's a very personal relationship
here
a small platform release of a movie like
this
and for you guys to laugh and clap it's
like if you hadn't it would
i would have felt like what roy choice
is your however everything sucks in the
world
so thank you you know i kind of left out
with iron man i didn't know how relevant
superheroes would be and they still
are but what's nice is i know to focus
on things that
there's a market for but as far as
cultural trends i think you just have to
tell a story that you enjoy so like all
the twitter stuff for example in chef
you realize how many people have read
this you're trending bro that was not
a conscious decision saying oh twitter's
popular let me use twitter
it was more what are the tools that a
chef uses what are the tools of our day
what's a personal story where i'm not
afraid of having to dumb it down so that
every single person understands it
and so it's what's personal to me and
that's what swingers was and that's what
iron man honestly the scenes in iron man
that were funny
were trying to make me laugh and
generally when you make you laugh
you make other people laugh and when you
try to make everybody laugh you make
nobody laugh
i thought yeah those are like my jokes
the more you do
you like the more i like it i don't know
nothing about them no context for a
korean restaurant but your enthusiasm
comes through
on one side you have that current events
aspect
which might if not handled right
alienate people to the film because you
want this to be fun and escapist
entertainment
but the way i decided to go was make it
in afghanistan
make it a comic book reality reflect the
images that
give all of us that collective anxiety
and frustration that i think we're all
feeling you have to reflect the times
comic books always have and then have
this hero come
in and sort of rescue us from the
situation
where we feel trapped or we might feel
powerless
so the more you give it a a context the
more
the cathartic escapist feeling you feel
when
the guy does win and the guy does fight
his way through it
and then you got to do it in a
responsible way where you're not just
waving a flag and saying blow everybody
up iron man is tony stark and tony stark
is a guy who goes from seeing things as
black and white and simplistic
to a guy who starts to understand the
complexity of the world and the effects
that
what his inventions and weapons have
done by introducing them
into the world so we tried to be
responsible but first and foremost we
did want to entertain and have this be
something you could escape to watch
what was that balance like for you how
much where did you find the sweet spot
there to make it i mean unfortunately i
worked on i worked on jungle books so i
had some experience in this area
and pretty early on because we've played
with different you know you get to try
different things and when you go too
human
you'd think it would make you feel more
but it really feels kind of bizarre at
least to me
so i was limited by what if we were
going to go photo real
if you go stylized like pixar it's great
you can do whatever you want if you make
madagascar you could
have them stick their tongues out if
it's tigger you could do whatever you
want
but the minute you start hitting photo
realism you hit the uncanny valley if
you push the performances beyond what
the real animal could do part of what
makes it look so real
is that we limited what we allowed the
animators to do it
um and and even for jungle book i drew
inspiration from do you remember
the film babe yeah i felt tremendous
connection to that character tremendous
emotion with that little pig
but there was no human expression on his
face it was a real pig with just a
little bit of cg to make the mouth move
and it taught me a lot about how we
convey emotion it's through the voice
it's through the storytelling and with
animals they express a lot of emotion
through their
their movement so if you look at a
character like like pumbaa
who um to me is the most fun example
because
when people saw pictures of pumbaa they
were like oh my god that's horrifying
that thing looks like a monster but when
you watch the movie and you see seth
rogen's voice coming out of it and the
way the anime has animated his body and
what the character represents and feels
you have a
tremendous connection to it so it's a
testament to
you know what the power of using
techniques that
we borrow from let's say documentaries
or from from other films where
we don't we limit ourselves to not
anthropomorphizing the characters what
you could accomplish
how does your experience as a director
influence your acting and vice versa
uh i'd say i learned more as a director
from being an actor than vice versa
i've had the good fortune of being able
to apprentice i'm sort of a de facto
apprentice on these movies i'm an actor
on because i get to
follow the watch the director follow him
around ask him questions
ask all the department heads uh
questions on the set
and that was my learning that was my
film school i got to watch directors
direct
and then i try to emulate the ones that
i respect most directors don't have that
experience you come out of film school
or you write a script or you get you
pull money together and you're on a set
for the first time you're on a set
you're the boss
that's a weird way to learn how to do
something and so being on other people's
sets and watching the flow of work and
watching how they handle people
gave me a tremendous leg up on other
people who were other first-time
directors who had never
had that experience
[Music]
you